[Musik]
am Anfang mussten wir erstm das Gelände
erkunden wir haben viel drüber gelernt
wie man sich in Gruppen durch den Wald
[Musik]
bewegt
ja und ein war es komplett finster und
das war natürlich sehr lustig dann noch
ein Unterkunft
aufzubauen das Exerzieren übt in der
vierten Woche richtig
intensiv
und dann ging es für uns zur
[Musik]
angedung die letzten vier Wochen waren
wir der
Achterbahn aber jede Herausforderung hat
uns wieder
[Musik]
zusammengeschweißt mein Vaterland die
Republik
Österreich Volk zu schützen jetzt kann
ich sagen es war hart aber ich bin stolz
ein Teil von diesem krassen Abenteuer zu
sein und im
Österreich
[Musik]
zu
ه